for me and also Wu-Tang Clan we made 36
Chambers eating a bunch of pizza maybe
about 5 000 boxes went through making 36
changes real talk
[Music]
[Music]
Dollar Pizza is the lifeblood of New
York City for just a buck anybody in the
five boroughs could fill up on a hot
slice Dollar Pizza will always have a
special place in my heart but a lot of
times you get what you pay for a lower
quality product at a lower price so
today I'm sitting out on a mission to
make the ultimate budget-friendly Pizza
a pie that won't break the bank but also
tastes delicious my challenge today is
my pal Scott weiner from Scott's Pizza
tours Scott is practically a dollar
slice historian and he's been waiting
for his chance to leave the judges table
and get his hands dirty in the kitchen
and of course we have a pair of Heavy
Hitters as our judges today Raekwon the
chef is a founding member of the
legendary hip-hop group Wu-Tang Clan and
a hardcore piece of obsessive and Mike
Phantom is the chef owner behind Ops one
of Brooklyn's favorite pizzerias can I
whip up a slice good enough to make
Raekwon and Mike part with their
hard-earned dollars there's only one way
to find out
foreign
to have you back on these tours thank
you for having me I am thrilled to be on
this side of the counter so today is all
about the dollar slice can you give us a
little crash course on the history of
the dollar slice yeah so like pizza was
a dollar per slice in the 80s yes
there's always been this Theory and this
concept that the price of a slice was
always matching the price of the subway
fare that's pretty much the case but
then around 2007-2008 the economy
started to tank
pizza by the slice kept going up and the
whole idea of that dollar slice was
let's make it with some slimmed down
ingredients and let's make sure that
it's just always hot and fresh and this
way we can guarantee that we'll have
volume that will keep us in business
so Scott here's the challenge today can
we make Pizza that we can't sell for a
dollar slice yeah of course we can I
think we can too we can do anything I
mean easy breezy the floor is yours what
you got going on I got just what you see
in front of you this is you know typical
dollar slice dough we're not using
freshly milled Ein corn I'm not using my
sourdough starter right this is simple
Basics commercial yeast all-purpose
flour what matters the most about dough
is the touch all right now
you know dollar slices never have enough
sauce good tomatoes are not that
expensive but I gotta say I'm not using
San Marzano Italian Tomatoes right I'm
using tomatoes from the Garden State New
Jersey okay which are good tomatoes
they're fantastic and they're not our
arm and a leg right so next thing I'm
gonna do is pecorino oh yeah you got
into the peppers
people are all like oh parmesan and I'm
like but wait a second parm is expensive
pecorino
cheaper so far my dough is like a 25
cent dough okay right and then my tomato
sauce is 10 12 13 cents that's it that
pecorino so far is the most expensive
thing on there but I use just a little
pinch and look yeah I'm not using
Buffalo mozzarella I'm using low
moisture mozzarella and then I'm doing
little bits of sauce just right on top
of that cheese
that's it now this is about to go in the
oven
I'm gonna can I turn this down turn it
down a little bit yeah I mean this Zuni
oven is rocking I can get this thing to
950. Rock It dollar slice shop doesn't
have that oven they don't no so but the
uni can be tweaked down right easily a
lot of people forget about that when it
comes to the uni well you know what when
you own a Ferrari you got to drive it
fast
I'm getting drive real slow okay here it
is ready
here we go looking good
here we go here's what gets really
exciting about this is that we're doing
a dollar slice
so I want to do a dollar slice there you
go oh make a Big Slice that's so cool
and then you get a little bonus Pizza on
the side and you get yourself a little
Wu-Tang logo
you did it you did it so now me and you
are going to eat this yeah we wanted to
share a slice yeah let's share it ready
one two three
so delicious this doesn't even taste
like a dollar that Char you don't get
that chocolate slice
but you could you could look that oven
costs like a fraction of what a dollar
size pizza oven costs it sure does so I
feel like you really nailed this I mean
you came in under a dollar this is
amazing
it's good but I've eaten my own pizza
before I love this I want yours when do
I get it
um coming up next
so Scott your pizza was absolutely
ingenious I loved everything you did so
my Approach is me thinking about two
things cost effective for the pizza
maker at home and also just making a
fantastic pizza for a dollar or under
all right so here we go first thing
we're gonna do is just open up our dough
so this dough is King Arthur
bread flour dough
easy peasy this has to be 25 cents big
bag of flour but you get a ton of those
out of that yeah I'm gonna just try to
go for a little smaller Conicelli those
Dollar Store crusts deliver like really
big puffy even I didn't skip on my
tomato sauce I'm not gonna leave a lot
of y'all at home this is Dennis lost
tomatoes
classic though classic even in the
dollar stores they all the dollar slice
shops use good tomatoes yes but Savannah
just not enough so what we gonna do
we're gonna make enough I remember when
I used to make pizza at home I had it
down to a science because I wanted to
make a profit right so I knew it was
like a quarter cup of sauce exactly 200
grams of cheese per Pizza the dough was
always no more than 454.60 a pizza and I
remember my plain cheese pizza used to
come in at home at 3.53 so what we're
gonna do traditional New York Pizza you
know little oregano that was like a
penny we're gonna do a little pecorino I
had a little blend a little Fontina
little mozzarella this is the most
expensive part but this is where we go
all out this is where we go all out but
the thing is we don't want to put too
much cheese right
so just a little sprinkle if you really
want to
um save money on cheese at home you you
buy the block cheese and you shred it
now we're gonna put this bad boy in
ready
okay my pieces came out of the oven so
you ready for a slice um of course I'm
ready you're gonna love this the
thickness is there the sauce is there
okay let's get the bite all right
[Music]
you know how when you go to the dollar
slice shop and that first bite and you
get that choo choo choo choo this is
that dough ball size was perfect cheese
to Sauce ratio is on
flavor profile of the sauce is perfect
texture of the crust is there it's the
dollar slice and you fed it to me and I
thank you you're welcome my pleasure all
right Scott you've been here before you
know the drill so it's time to go to the
judge's table we got New York rap Legend
from the whoa Raekwon the chef he's a
dollar slice Aficionado and we also have
Mike Tatum from Ops here I really
beloved pizza shops in Brooklyn so let's
see what they think you ready no but I
have no choice I love him
[Music]
what I love about the dollar slice in
New York is it just takes you back to
being a kid just stopping for a dollar
slice
um it was fun it was it was part of you
know envisioning where you from your
neighborhood you can't come to Manhattan
and not have a slice I don't care who
you are so yeah for me like a dollar
slice it brings me back to moving to New
York for college and not having any
money this is the thing that's gonna
fill me up I grew up in St Louis and
Philadelphia and I you don't have these
slice shops you can just go to it's
always available to you whenever you're
hungry doing anything in the city it's
just such a part of New York for me and
also Wu-Tang Clan we made 36 Chambers
eating a bunch of pizza I don't know
maybe we wrote crazy Rhymes just after
eating a good pie because when it was a
bad one we'd be like yo get that [ __ ]
out of here man like yo you don't want
that [ __ ] you know we ain't eating that
and then that could create a vibe in the
room yeah I would say probably
maybe about 5 000 boxes went through
making 36 changes real talk so yo check
it out y'all you know it's about that
time right
got my dollar I need that slice y'all
let's get it going I got mine too
[Music]
so Mike it's that time
you know me and use Pizza Kings that's
right so we going for it I'm ready all
right let's go for it let's do it let's
do it
[Music]
they fascinated me with making it burn I
love my pizza like that you know
so they get it they get a 10 on that you
know
just the just the timing of when it came
out
it felt right the cheese is like exactly
what you want the cheese to be on a
dollar slice I think got that big cheese
pole I love um how chunky the sauce is a
lot of places they'd be kind of like
cheap with this with the tomato sauce
definitely so for it to have that good
chunk chunk of marinara involved with it
the crust
yeah nothing bad to say take one more
for y'all
I got just one one piece of criticism
for this pizza which is I feel like
especially with the sliced joint pizza I
want a little less crust to base ratio
I think I would have stretched it a
little bit a little bit more and got a
little more cheese and sauce on the
pizza itself you know when I think of a
Dollar Pizza
I think of it being a little bit bigger
but it took me back to being a kid again
it did I think we are to a great start
right here and then you ready to try the
next one I'm ready yeah yeah let's go
let's get it
so Mike we here once again I look
I mean we're definitely looking at
something a little closer to what we
were talking about it's like nice and
big
I agree
but look they kind of they kind of
freaked the cheese a little bit I did
something a little different this time
it looks look like raviolis in there to
me ah SpaghettiOs or something what we
doing let's say goodbye you ready I can
keep an open mind I'm ready all right
let's do this all right
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
like a size and the proportions looks a
little more closer to what you know I'm
used to with a dollar slice I think the
the way the cheese was put on the pizza
is a little weird for me but I do like
the way this like
definitely accentuated the tomato sauce
which was like nice and sweet and like
kind of Jammy the cheese it went it went
somewhere else the sauce was a little
bit overdosed I felt like I had a tomato
sandwich to a degree it was good
but great I got some things on my mind
about it so Mike it's about that time we
had two great slices and it's time
to keep it 100 you ready I'm ready let's
go for it
Raekwon Mike welcome to peace Awards
we're so will to have you thank you
thank you to be here definitely Scott
and I had a ball with a Dollar Pizza
challenge we're friends yes
this is about friendship dollars are all
about coming together so yes thanks for
letting us do this well first thing I
want to say Nicole is that you guys uh
dope at what you do I like my pizza to
be pretty looking
pizza was gorgeous when I think of my
dollar slices
it's almost like it has to be perfect
it's just analyzing the first pizza
don't know whose it is
it was good the sauce was where it
needed to be
crust a little on the heavy side only
because it was short and for the second
pie the size was a lot better and the
crust like the thickness was better but
then again like the cheese to Sauce
ratio and the difference of the two
was a little off for me Scott and I we
really take your criticism to heart we
totally get it trust me so what's your
final verdict Nicole Scott
y'all ready for this ready coupon ready
all right so let's let's separate the
garlic from the the onions right
damn the winner
is
keep it real oh yeah keep it a thousand
Mike talk to me keep it a thousand
thousand Keep it a thousand thousand win
is number one oh
[ __ ]
you did that all right now Pizza Wars
Nicole congratulations
[Applause]
you're the best and I'll see you next
time on pizza wars
[Music]
[Music]